- Alors, revenons sur les
nouvelles mesures sanitas s s sr
avec la docteure Cécile
Tremblay, microbiologiste
et infectiologue au CHUM
bonsoir.- Bonsoir, Madame Assel.
- Alors, est-ce que ces mesures
sont s
la catastrophe appréhendée
dans les hôpitaux?
Dre CÉCILE TREMBLAY,
microbio.-infectiologue, CHUM
m'apparaît tout à fait approprié
dans les circonstances.
Est-ce que ça va être suffisant?
des prochains jours
et des pnenenenes semaines,
mais je pense que c'était
un bon pas que le gouv faire.
- Oui, parce que ce que disait
monsieur Dubé, le ministre
de la Santé, c'est qu'on
l'impact réel d'Omicron
sur les hospitnsnsnsnsns,
sur la gravité de la maladie.
- En fait, on a des études
aujourd'hui même, qui nous
viennent d'Angleterre et
d'Écosse, qui semblent indiquer
qu'Omicron serait 40 %...
il y aurait '''''''''''''''''''é
avec Omicron qu'avec le variant
Delta, ce qui est une bonne
nouvelle qui voudrait,,,,,,,,,,,
dans les modèles de projection
de l'INSPQ, dans le scénario
Mais le scénario le plus
favorable nous menait
des hospitalisations,
à la mi-ji i i i i i était
insoutenable pour le système.
- Oui, il y a ététététététude
aussi qui nous vient d'Afrique
du Sud qui nous apprendlalalalan
du variant Omicron, le nombre
de cas est déjà en baisse.
Le nombre de contaminations
est déjà en bais
est-ce que... Vous dites
que c'est de bon augure, l'étude
sud-africaine aussi? Est-ce
qu'on peut... Est-ce qu'on peut
voir un peu de lumière au bout
- Je pense qu'on peut voir
re au bout du tunnel.
En fait, ce que ces deux études-
là nous dichchchchchchchchchchc,
parce que la double vaccinatio
dans l'étude d'Angleterre,
indique que... corrèle
contre la maladie sévère.
Donc, les gens qui ne sont pas
le même taux d'hospitalisation
qu D D D D D D Donc, ce que ça
nous dit, c'est que si on va
chercher notre t
qu'on augmente encore plus la
protection contre l'infection,
on va commencer à voir une
pic qui va arriver probablemente
décroissance dans un contexte
vont être très bien protégés
avec une troisiè
vaccin. Donc oui, ça devrait
nous donner espoir et ça devrai.
à suivre les consignes qui nous
ont été données, paranananananas
au maximum, en allant chercher
notre troisième dose de vaccin,
qu'on va arriver à ce résultat-
là.
- Donc, un souper de Noël
à 10 persons s s s s s s s fait
pas trop peur?
- Bien, à 10 personnes, s s s st
vaccinés, en autant qu'on essaie
de ne pas inviter des gens
qui sont vulnérables, qui sont
âgées, en ouvrant les fenêtres,
je pense que ça peut se faire.nt
obligés de faire un souper à
Si on peut faire un souper
c', , , , , , , , , mais
au moins, ça donne un peu
d'air frais à la sososososososo.
- Voilà. Docteure Cécile